moving on in Israel's Ultra nationalist
security minister isama bengavir has led
an incursion into the Al-Aqsa mosque
compound in occupied East Jerusalem now
Thursday marks the Jewish holiday of
Tisha bayav which commemorates the
destruction of the second Jewish temple
in the year 70 A.D
nearly 2 000 Israeli Ultra nationalist
settlers entered under police protection
non-muslims are allowed inside the
compound but are not permitted to pray
under a decades-old agreement known as
the status quo however since the current
far-right government took power Israeli
settlers and politicians have been
increasingly defying the ban Jordan
takier and Saudi Arabia have all
condemned the incursion calling it
provocative
today in this place always to remind us
that we are all Brothers right wing left
wing religious seculars we are one
nation whoever looks to us from outside
they will see no differences between us
and nothing will separate us the unity
of the nation of Israel is important and
this place is important for us and we
have to return to it and prove our
sovereignty
well let's bring in our correspondent
Muhammad Jam he joins us now from West
Jerusalem Muhammad what's the scene like
at Al-Aqsa now
there's Anastasia uh the visiting hours
for the ultra nationalists who had gone
into the Alexa mosque compound which you
see behind me there
um those have ended they ended a little
over an hour and a half ago it has been
cleared out of the ultra nationalists uh
the scene at the moment is calm we're
told everything is returned to normal
that the Muslim worshipers that had been
denied entry to the Al-Aqsa mosque
compound in the last few hours that they
have now been allowed entry that they
have resumed any prayers that they want
to make and also we have been told that
over the course of the day it was
reported from an Israeli media that
there were at least three Palestinians
that were arrested but there were also
several Israelis uh Ultra nationalists
who were arrested because they had
attempted to pray when they were in the
mosque compound and that as you
mentioned just a moment ago that is
something that is not allowed under the
status quo agreement
has been such a Flashpoint and such
incidents in the past have often led to
violence are there any concerns around
that this time
there were concerns earlier today there
had been scenes of tension there had
been confrontations and as you mentioned
this is a flash point this is an area
where things can escalate very very
quickly that did not happen today but
still there were concerns the fact that
the national security minister itmar
bengafir that he led in Persian into the
Al-Aqsa mosque compound known to Jews as
the Temple mount that is something that
caused a great deal of concern you had
the statements that you mentioned from
the Jordanian foreign ministry as well
as the Palestinian Authority saying that
that was against the status quo
agreement that it was a very provocative
a very provocative action that should be
condemned also we heard from the U.S
embassy the U.S embassy issued a
statement in which they said that the
U.S stands firmly for the preservation
of the historic status quo with respect
to the holy sites in Jerusalem and that
any unilateral action or rhetoric that
jeopardizes the status quo is
unacceptable that is something obviously
that's in response to Mr Ben gevir's
incursion into the Al-Aqsa mosque
compound there's been a lot of
condemnation in the past when Mr Ben
gavir has decided to make an appearance
this is the third time that he has gone
to the Al-Aqsa Moss compound since
becoming the national security minister
in Israel earlier this year at something
that is seen as a provocative action
because it is believed that that will
encourage more Ultra nationalists to try
to go into the compound and to try to
then pray in that compound it's a
feeling of entitlement amongst them it's
something that that is provocative it's
something that causes a lot of anger and
it's something that a lot of
international players want to see come
to an end Mama Jam there across all the
latest for us thank you Muhammad
well Israeli soldiers have shot and
killed a Palestinian teenager during
their latest raid in the occupied West
Bank Witnesses in calcilia say that the
14 year old boy held rocks at troops who
then responded with gunfire the Israeli
military has been carrying out near
nightly raids it says to clear the West
Bank of armed groups 39 children are
among 207 Palestinians killed by Israeli
forces in the occupied Palestinian
territories so far this year